la pression s'accentue autour de google
après la plainte déposée par l'ancien
président donald trump contre les géants
du numérique dont google
la plateforme numérique est désormais la
cible d'une nouvelle procédure a tenté
par 36 états ainsi que le district de
columbia
trente sept procureurs généraux qui se
sont donc associés pour distille mettre
fin au monopole illégal de google ils
lui reprochent à des méthodes anti
concurrentielles notamment en
décourageant à l'installation
d'applications par un autre moyen que le
plextor installé d'office sur les
téléphones android
des accusations dont se défend google
dans un communiqué nous comprenons qu'un
examen soit opportun et nous sommes
prêts à nous engager avec les
régulateurs mais android et google play
fournissent une ouverture et un choix
que les autres plateformes ne permettent
pas cette procédure ne va pas aider les
petits ou protéger les consommateurs
mais cela va profiter à une poignée de
grands développeurs d'applications qui
veulent les bénéfices de google play
sont payés
google se défend donc notamment en se
comparant avec d'autres acteurs du
marché on comprend qu'il ait fait
référence à apple mais apple est
également visé par une plainte pour des
faits est relativement similaire par un
éditeur de jeux vidéo alors ses actions
en justice illustre la volonté aux états
unis de s'attaquer au monopole de ces
géants du numérique qui ont engrangé des
bénéfices records ces derniers mois il
ya quelques semaines une commission
parlementaire avait décidé une série de
projets de loi pour l'emport s'attaquer
aux situations de monopole l'europe a
longtemps était seul sur ce dossier il
semblerait donc qu'il y ait un
changement aux états unis on verra
maintenant comment tout cela va se
concrétiser
et si cette stratégie aura de véritables
conséquences pour ces géants du
numérique